-The Justice Department
has responded
to Donald Trump's attempt
to get the Supreme Court
to intervene
in the criminal investigation
of his stolen
classified documents
and yet, even as that
criminal case intensifies
and more evidence emerges,
Republicans are still
fully onboard
with Trump and Trump's
handpicked candidates,
like Herschel Walker,
who's also dealing
with more bombshell revelations
in his abortion scandal.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
The looming midterms have
proven, once again,
that the Republican Party
still remains fully captive
to Donald Trump and his cabal.
In key battleground races
across the country,
the Republicans running
for House, Senate, governor,
and even Secretary of State
are pro-Trump, MAGA candidates,
in many cases, endorsed or even
handpicked by Trump himself.
And that's never good
because Trump always picks
the weirdest people he can find,
[ Laughter ]
like Steve Bannon;
or the pillow guy;
or even his own lawyer, a man --
[ Laughter ]
a man who sweats like he just
got out of a sauna
after sleeping there overnight.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Giuliani ]
I had the weirdest dream,
where I was a 7-Eleven hot dog.
You know --
[ Laughter ]
You know, the guy
who wears golf shorts
that go from his belly button
down to his ankles.
[ Laughter ]
Like he accidentally bought
a pair of child's khakis.
[ Laughter ]
Look at that dude.
Looks like a 1920s newsie
who got stranded
on that beach
that makes you old.
[ As Giuliani ]
Extry! Extry!
I forgot what I was going
to say.
[ Laughter ]
I can make fun of Rudy's
giant shorts all day.
For example, he looks like he's
in a Disney movie called...
[ Laughter ]
But I am being tol...d
that I have to get to the point.
Alright, well, Trump's latest
handpicked disaster is
Herschel Walker, the GOP
candidate for Senate in Georgia.
Trump personally urged Walker
to run,
despite warnings --
from fellow Republicans,
it should be noted --
about Walker's troubled past
and, sure enough, Walker is now
engulfed in a growing scandal,
which includes
the latest revelation
that the mother
of one of Walker's children had
to repeatedly press him to pay
for an abortion he wanted.
And, much like Trump,
Walker has tried
to distract
from the mounting scandals
by doing and saying
some very strange things.
Yesterday, for example,
Walker told this
incredibly bizarre story
about a bull and some cows
at a campaign rally.
-So I've been telling
this little story
about this ball
out in the field with six cows
and three of them are pregnant.
[ Rally laughter ]
So you know he got something
going on.
[ Rally laughter ]
But all he cared about is
kept his nose against the fence,
looking at three other cows
that didn't belong to him.
Now, all he had to do is
eat grass.
But no, no, no,
he thought something was better
somewhere else.
So, he decided,
"I want to get over there."
So, one day,
he measured that fence up
and he said,
"I think I can jump this."
So, that came where he got back.
And he got back
and, as he took off running,
he dove over that fence
and his belly got cut up
under the bottom.
But as he made it over
on the other side,
he shook it off
and got so excited about it
and he ran
to the top of that hill,
but when he got up there,
he realized
they were bulls, too.
[ Laughter ]
So, what I'm telling you...
[ Applause ]
...don't think something is
better somewhere else.
[ Laughter ]
-Kind of feels like a bad idea
for Herschel Walker
to be telling any stories
about multiple
random pregnancies,
especially one where
the expectant dad
just peaces out like that.
[ Laughter ]
I don't even understand
the logic here.
A bull got
three cows pregnant,
then he saw some more cows
on the other side of a fence
and so he jumped the fence to go
have sex with the other cows,
but then when he got closer,
he realized the cows
were actually bulls.
Are you misremembering
a Sandra Boynton book?
[ Laughter ]
Also, I want to revisit
this part of the story.
-This ball out in the field
with six cows
and three of them are pregnant.
So you know he got something
going on.
-He said that
like it was gossip,
[ Laughter ]
like the cows --
the cows were all whispering
to each other
while they were
out chewing grass, just like --
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, my God.
Did you hear Dottie, Clarabelle,
and Buttercup are pregnant?
[ Laughter and applause ]
And word is
they're all Kenny's?"
[ Laughter ]
"Well, can you blame them?
Look at those eyes!"
[ Laughter ]
Also, notably, there were
two other Republicans onstage
with Walker --
Senators Tom Cotton
and Rick Scott.
They were there to show
mainstream GOP support
for Walker,
even amid all the scandals,
and I can't imagine they were
hoping for that story.
"Alright, Herschel,
just stay on message
and talk about tax cuts
and inflation."
Cool, yeah, right after
my cow sex story.
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah, but maybe --
maybe it's just better
to focus on inflation?"
100%, but I need to warm 'em up
with the cow sex story.
[ Laughter ]
"Herschel!"
So, the GOP has, once again,
made a devil's bargain
with Trump
and his MAGA movement.
In fact, Mitch McConnell
made the bargain explicit
in an interview he gave
to CNN yesterday.
McConnell was asked
if he has a litmus test
for Republican candidates,
then said he doesn't care
who the candidates are
or what they do.
He only cares about winning.
-When I asked him, "Do you
prefer Republican candidates
who might be
in the mold of Donald Trump;
or Liz Cheney, who battled
Donald Trump's election lies;
he said, "I'm for candidates
who will win
and I don't have a litmus test,
one way or the other."
-Trump versus Cheney,
essentially asking
Leader McConnell,
"Which Republican Party
would you prefer,
Liz Cheney or Donald Trump?"
-In a way,
I appreciate the honesty
and I'm sure, as he said it,
he was doing that creepy
little smile he does,
you know,
like he's in that new movie.
[ Laughter and applause ]
McConnell and the GOP
have made it clear
they don't care how badly Trump
and his cronies
degrade our institution.
They just want to win,
so, they're going
to keep seeking lower.
I mean, they'd support
the bull from Walker's story,
[ Laughter ]
if they thought
he had a chance to win.
[ As McConnell ]
Oh, he explained himself.
He thought the bulls
on the other side of the fence
were cows.
[ Laughter ]
Now, you know,
his belly's all cut up.
[ Laughter ]
We all make mistakes."
[ Applause ]
The GOP is fully behind
all these Trump-backed
candidates,
who are also campaigning
with Trump
and appearing at his rallies,
even as Trump remains
under a serious
federal criminal investigation
into the highly classified
documents he stole
from the White House
and stashed at Mar-A-Lago.
In fact, The New York Times
just recently reported
that officials suspect
Trump may still have
even more documents
in his possession,
that he's still not returned
to the government,
in addition to the materials
the FBI
has already seized
from Mar-A-Lago.
-New reporting
by The New York Times,
which NBC News has confirmed,
reveals that the DOJ told
Trump's lawyers,
in recent weeks,
they believe Trump
still has more documents
he has not returned
to the National Archives.
The New York Times
reporting that it's...
-Oh, does the
Justice Department suspect
that Donald Trump may not be
fully cooperative?
That's like a guy with claw
marks all over his face
telling you his cat
wasn't fully cooperative
with its Halloween costume.
[ Laughter ]
Donald Trump not being
fully cooperative
with an investigation is
as shocking
as the Mets winning 101 games
and then blowing it in the first
round of the playoffs.
[ Oohs and laughter ]
And guys, that's it!
That's it for Mets jokes
this week.
[ Laughter ]
Am I a Mets fan?
No, I am not.
But a lot of the people
who keep this show running
smoothly every day are.
And I will admit that,
over the course of the season,
I started rooting
for this Mets team.
And, sure, they didn't win it
all, but it's pretty cool
they did as well as they did,
considering that, while other
teams have giant payrolls,
they made it work
with a ragtag budget.
What's that?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, they have the highest
payroll in the league?
Oh, okay.
How much was it?
A quarter of a billion dollars?!
Oh, well, you know.
Oh, I bet whoever's
inside Mr. Met
is a hardworking young --
Oh, it's Rudy Giuliani?!
[Bleep] me!
[ Laughter and applause ]
You guys, I said that was
the only Mets joke
I was going to make this week.
You want to hear the real burn?
I did it on Monday.
We had to cut it for time,
so the crew had
to hear it twice.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
And one of the crew members
came up to me today
and he's like,
"You're going
to [bleep] burn me twice
and think I'm going to show up
tomorrow and support you?"
And I'm like, "Well,
the Mets have burned you more
than [bleep] twice
and you still support them."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And then my crew member
just tipped his cap. He said --
It's a really cool thing.
They all were little caps.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Where were we?
Oh, right.
Of course Trump still has
more government documents
in his possession.
He's not the kind of guy
who's good at returning things.
If Donald Trump borrows
your lawnmower,
you're going to need to buy
a new lawnmower.
[ Laughter ]
I bet the copy
of "Goodnight Moon"
he read his kids was stamped
with Property
of New York Public Library."
[ Laughter ]
Now, before we move on,
which one of those was harder
for you to imagine --
Donald Trump mowing a lawn all
by himself
or Donald Trump reading
"Goodnight Moon"
to a young Eric and Don Jr.?
[ As Trump ]
"In the great green room --"
And it was -- What a room.
One of the greatest.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And just the most beautiful
mush you've ever seen.
Just gorgeous, gorgeous mush,
gold-plated mush.
[ Laughter ]
You know why the cow is jumping
over the moon?
So we could get
away from a horny bull.
[ Laughter and applause ]
A football player
told me that story.
Point is,
even after 18 months of pleading
from the National Archives,
and an FBI search,
officials think this guy might
still be holding back documents
that belong to the government.
I can't even imagine
the sheer sense
of impunity and entitlement
you have to have
to just completely ignore
the law like that.
One time a cop pulled me over
on the highway
and I immediately
just started sobbing
before I could even
roll down the window.
And then he said he just wanted
to tell me my trunk was open
and then I said,
"Oh, thank you so much.
That's where I keep
all my meth,"
[ Laughter and applause ]
because I make jokes
when I'm nervous.
And then he didn't even look
in the trunk.
He just said,
"You don't have the balls
to move crystal.
Drive safely."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Very rude!
Uh, very rude.
Now, as we told you last week,
Trump appealed the ruling
in the case
over his stolen documents
directly to the Supreme Court,
hoping the Trump appointees
on the court
would bail him out and intervene
to slow down the investigation.
It just so happens the appeal
was addressed specifically
to one particular justice,
with a personal connection
to Trump.
-Attorneys for the ex-president
made an attempt
to block DOJ's
criminal investigation
by asking the U.S. Supreme Court
to reverse a ruling
by an appeals court
that gives the DOJ access
to classified documents
that were seized at Mar-A-Lago.
-The justice overseeing
the 11th Circuit,
whose decision
Trump is appealing,
is none other
than Clarence Thomas.
Now, in addition to being,
arguably,
the most conservative justice
on the court,
Thomas is also the husband
of far-right activist
Ginni Thomas,
who, in addition to pushing
bonkers QAnon
conspiracy theories
to Trump White House officials,
also personally worked to try
and help facilitate
Trump's attempted coup.
-Trump must've been so psyched
when he found out the justice
who would review the case
was Clarence Thomas.
It's like finding out your mom
started dating
your high school math teacher.
"Hell yeah!
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to ace this class.
Doug is so horny for my mom,
he told me I don't even have
to show up for exams!
[ Laughter ]
I feel bad for Dad, though."
Yeah! In that story,
the kid's mom was still married.
[ Laughter ]
None of you thought about him.
Everybody here should be ashamed
of themselves.
[ Laughter ]
Well, now,
the Justice Department
has responded to that filing
with a filing of its own,
urging the Supreme Court to stay
out of the case altogether,
telling the court Trump has
no legitimate ownership
of any of the classified
documents under review.
-The Justice Department
sending a clear message
to the Supreme Court --
"Stay out
of the Mar-A-Lago
documents dispute."
-The Justice Department
asking the Supreme Court
to reject Mr. Trump's request
that the court clear the way
for the documents to be turned
over to his lawyers
and a special master
for review.
The Justice Department says
Mr. Trump cannot make any
personal claim to the papers
and has offered no evidence
he declassified them.
-Yeah, I mean, it's obvious
there's no reason
the Supreme Court, or any court,
should step in
to delay the investigation
because the classified documents
are obviously not his.
Do we really need nine people
in robes to tell us
if this was just stuff
he brought with him from home?
Trump's acting like a guy
who got fired
and then tried to leave
with the copy machine.
"You guys were all here
on my first day.
I had my tiny plant,
my Wayne Gretzky Bobblehead,
and my industrial-size
copy machine.
[ Laughter ]
You remember, Barb.
You helped me wheel it in!"
Remember, some of the documents
Trump stole
were nuclear secrets.
Are we supposed to believe
those were his
and he just brought them
with him from home,
like, before he was president,
he was looking at aerial photos
with a magnifying lens?
[ As Trump ]
Mel! Mel!
I'm seeing some
very interesting images
from the drone flights
I commissioned.
[ Laughter ]
Mel, you're going to want
to see -- Mel, Mel, honey,
you have
to take out your AirPods.
[ Laughter ]
Well, you can't hear --
Why are you putting headphones?
Mel, don't put headphones on
over the EarPods.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, Mel!
The various scandals engulfing
Herschel Walker's campaign
and the GOP's decision
to stand by him, no matter what,
are just the latest examples
of how Trump
has completely transformed
the GOP.
Even as he remains
under multiple
serious criminal investigations
they remain fully captive
to Trump,
a man who is much
like Herschel Walker --
constantly spewing...
-Bull.
-This has been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
..."A Closer Look."
[ Cheering ]
♪♪
The midterm elections
are coming up, so,
to make sure that you're good
to vote in this election,
visit our good friends
at headcount.org
to check your voter registration
status or to register to vote.